[Music]
[Applause]
this is a talk about my favorite
featuring go many years ago Rob Pike
remarked that numbers are just numbers
you will never see Oh X ull in a go
source file and behind this pithy
observation lies the fascinating world
of constants in go and it's something
that is perhaps taken for granted
because as Rob noted numbers constants
in God they just work so today I'm going
to show you a few things that perhaps
you didn't know about the Const keyword
and go to kick it off like why what's so
great about constants immutability
constants are one of the very few ways
we have to tell the compiler that this
number will not change or this this
value will not change clarity constants
give us a way to extract those magic
numbers out of our code and give them
names and give them semantic meaning and
and obviously performance um the ability
to say to the compiler this does not
change is a key optimization it unlocks
constant folding constant propagation
branch branch elimination dead code
elimination a whole slew of
optimizations but so what these are all
generic use cases for constants like any
language sending any compiled language
can do these things but we here at go we
serve at the pleasure of leg affair so
let's talk about some of the ways that
we can use these properties of gos
constants and let's do this with a
little challenge so your challenge is to
declare a constant whose value is the
number of bits in the machine word now
you can't use unsafe sizeof because
that's not a constant expression you
can't assign that to a constant you
could make a big kind of bird's nest of
build
and record like the various word sizes
for every different platform that we
support but in the future you're gonna
have to keep that up to date and that's
that's big and messy so instead we could
do something like this there are many
versions of this in the go codebase they
all work roughly the same if we're on
say a 64-bit platform then taking the
exclusive-or of the number 0 gives us 64
once we shift that 32 bits to the right
and then we end that with a number with
just one in the five digit 1 and 1 is 1
and then finally we shift the number 30
to one place to the left and that gives
us 64 so you can do this arithmetic at
home for the 32-bit platforms if you
like so this is an example of a constant
expression all of those operations
happened at compile time and the result
of evaluating that expression is also a
constant if you have a look in the
runtime package specifically the garbage
collector you're going to see
expressions like this used to set up
very complex invariants that don't
require build tags and unsafe of and
things like that to tune themselves to
the specific machine so this is a cool
party trick but again most compilers can
do things like this perhaps not as
elegantly as go can but muslim' can do
this kind of constant folding so let's
let's step it up a notch in go constants
are values and every value has a type in
go user-defined types can declare their
own methods
we all know this thus a constant value
can have a method set if you're a little
bit surprised by this statement let me
show you example that we use every
single day so
here we have the untyped literal 500
multiplied by the time duck millisecond
constant which is a time duration now
the rules for assignment in go say that
unless the type is declared on the
left-hand side of the assignment it's
assumed from the right so we have the
untyped literal 500 it's converted to a
time duration because that is the type
of time that millisecond and they're
multiplied together and you get the
value 500 million so on the left hand
side we have a constant its name is
timeout its type is timed iteration and
its value is 500 million so why then
does it print 500 MS and the reason for
this is time duration has a string
method thus any time dr.ali
duration value even a constant knows how
to pretty print itself now we know that
constant values are typed
and because types can declare methods we
can derive that constant values can
fulfill interfaces I mean we saw an
example of that just before the fault
package doesn't assert that the values
it was given have a string method it
asserts that they fulfill the stringer
interface so let's talk a little bit how
we can use this property to make our go
code better and to do that I'm going to
take a little digression into the
singleton pattern I'm generally not a
fan of the singleton pattern in go or
any language Singleton's really
complicate your testing they create
unnecessary coupling between your
packages and I think I feel the
singleton pattern is often used not to
create one instance of something but
instead to create a place where things
like find each other and register each
other a really good example of that is
HTTP default serve MUX this is not a
singleton
there is nothing singular about it
nothing prevents you from creating
another serve marks in fact we even give
you a helper to make as many as you like
so this is not a singleton nevertheless
there is a case for some things which
really truly are singular because they
can only represent a single thing an
example that I think one of the best
examples of that our file descriptors
the numbers 0 1 & 2 when interpreted as
file descriptors represent standard in
out and error now it doesn't matter what
name you give the variable holding 0 1 1
0 1 & 2 and it doesn't because 1 always
means standard out and they can only
ever be one file descriptor 1 so on the
screen these two operations are
identical so let's look at how the hours
per OS package declares them this is
that this is from the standard library
now there are a few problems with this
declaration the first is that the types
of those variables are files they are
not the respective reader and writer and
closer that that you might expect now
people have long complained that this
makes replacing those declarations
problematic but the notion of replacing
them is precisely the point of this
digression because can you safely change
any of those once this program is
running without causing a data race
argue to you that in the general case
you cannot replace them in general if
something is unsafe to do as programmers
we shouldn't really let us let them
think that it is safe because they might
begin to depend on that behavior so can
we change the definition of standard out
and friends so that they retain their
observable behavior of reading and
writing but they become immutable and it
turns out we can do this very easily
with constants
for example we have a reed FD type it's
just an integer we give it a reed method
we do the same thing for a right ft we
give it a right method and now we can
declare constants of those types as
constant expressions and they behave
just like the standard OS versions do in
fact you can make this change in the
standard library and it causes one
compilation failure when you try to
build the standard library and I'll
leave it as an exercise to you to figure
out which package breaks another case of
things which look like constants but
aren't really our Sentinel error values
IOOF
SQL error no rows x.509 error
unsupported algorithm and so on are all
examples of Sentinel values and I say
this because they all fall into the
category of expected errors and because
these errors are expected we're all
expected to check for them how do we
check them to compare the error you have
with the one that you're expecting you
need to import the package that declares
that error and because by definition
Sentinel errors are exported public
variables any any code that imports for
example the IO package could redefine
what io io f is oh I'll just say this
again for clarity if I know the name of
io io f I can import the package that
declares it which in fact I must do if I
want to compare it to my error and thus
I could change its value now by
convention and probably a bit of dumb
luck this doesn't happen very often but
but technically there's nothing to
prevent you for scientific purposes only
I tried to make this change and I can
tell you that things stop working very
quickly
indeed Ruby programmer but replacing a
less frequently used central error value
might cause some more interesting side
effects are you absolutely sure that
none of your dependencies contain this
line if anyone in there is depending on
120 megabytes of source code from
kubernetes are you absolutely sure that
this doesn't happen and if you're hoping
that the race detector would spot this
kind of subterfuge I suggest that you
talk to the folks who are writing
testing frameworks who do replace our
standard out very carefully so they
don't trigger the race detector I'll
leave you to do your code or audits
later so putting aside the effect of
malicious actors in your codebase the
key design challenge with central errors
is that they behave like Singleton's not
constants and regrets remember to talk
about the most important property of a
constant constants aren't just immutable
it's not enough that we just can't
change their declaration constants are
fungible and this is a tremendously
important property that I think just
gets no attention fungible means
identical
I mean free money is a really good
example of this like if I asked to
borrow ten euros from somebody and then
I paid them back a week later the fact
that they gave me a ten euro note and I
gave them ten coins back from the point
of view of a negotiable instrument is
irrelevant the money's the same it works
the same
so things which are fungible are by
definition equal an equality is a really
powerful property that we can leverage
in our programs even if we follow the
exact procedure used by the IO package
this is the line that it's declared on
to create our own EOF value my EOF error
an IO a of' are not equal even though we
use the exact same procedure to make
them so when you combine the lack of
immutability they're like a fungibility
the lack of equality you have this
really weird set of behaviors that stem
from the fact that central error values
are not constant expressions but what if
we could do that what if we could make
them constant expressions ideally a
central error value should behave like a
constant it should be immutable it
should be functional let's recap how the
built-in error interface works any type
with an error string method fulfills the
error interface this includes
user-defined types this includes types
derived from Street primitives like
strings and this of course includes
constant strings so with that background
consider this error implementation we
can use this error type as a constant
expression we can't use the errors error
string type because that is a struct and
compact struct literal initializers are
not constant expressions so this can be
a constant where errors new cannot as
constants of the of our arrow type are
not variables they're immutable they
can't be changed and additionally two
constant strings are always equal if
their contents are equal so string 1 and
string 2 are equal so it follows that
two constants of a type derived from
string with the same contents are also
equal so to say this another way equal
constant error values are the same in
the same that the literal one in your
program is the same as all the other
literal ones
your program so now we have all the
pieces we need to make central error
values like IO IO f + RS a verification
error immutable fungible constant
expressions now this change is probably
a bit of a stretch for the go one
contract muscles going to talk later
about the much wider changes happening -
error handling and go I don't think it's
applicable to try to make this change to
the standard library but there's
absolutely no reason that you can't
adopt this pattern if you use Sentinel
aerators errors in your packages so
ghost constants are powerful um I think
if you're only think of them as like
immutable numbers or final numbers that
you can't change I think you're missing
out on a lot of their power ghost
constants let us compose programs that
are more correct and harder to misuse so
today I've given you three ways to use
constants they're probably just more
than a typical fixed number but now it's
over to you I'm excited to see what you
can do with these ideas thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]